like find someone that like is healthy
or good for me like I obviously want
that but that's not what I'm attracted
to and so I'm not like I'm not gonna
sell for someone that I'm not attracted
to just because
like they're good for me okay we're good
we're good that's a funny sentence I had
I was good I was with her and I am so
excited to say that I am currently
talking to someone new that is
n't giving me the bare minimum of daily
communication like I cannot help but
wonder if there is something wrong with
me do I put forth some sort of repellent
this is a sickness I'm happy for you my
girl the highest order tonight I came to
the conclusion that I am officially done
pursuing any sort of relationship I am
so tired
of thinking it's going to work out with
someone
and then it doesn't work like there's
literally no point for me anymore to
even try because one it's very rare that
I find someone that I actually feel like
opening up to and once I do open up to
someone like I assume that they feel the
same way about me as I do about them and
then there you go that's your problem
wrap it up you assume that they feel the
same way there you go stop assuming [__]
assuming [__] is the Killer
assuming [__] is the killer in anything
relationship friendships job you assume
things that means that you just didn't
ask you don't have the proper
information it's just like yeah that's
what it is and you're just walking in
that [__] blindly you assume oh let's
see what happens after she soon what
ends up happening is I just end up
getting hurt because
love really
really shoes
wrong people no
you got really really hurt because you
assume the other person exactly where
were you at and they weren't
what was it hello there's nothing wrong
with falling in love very quickly do
things at your own pace yeah sure but
what you can't do is just because you
can run a half marathon you expect
everybody else to go on a date with to
run the hair half marathon with you and
you feel me you might be a lot faster
than other people you might be slower
than others
that's one thing I tell people is like
and I've had relationships before where
I was ready for certain steps and my
partner wasn't
and I told them I was ready and they
said they weren't they felt a lot of
pressure I said no you don't have to
feel no pressure it's fine I'm here you
get there when you get there and I've
also been the one who's been late to
things where they've opened up a lot and
I wasn't there and I told them listen if
you ready to open up you can open up to
me but I'm not ready to share the same
things with you and you need to respect
that and if you opening up to me means I
gotta reciprocate then don't
because I feel like you rushing me
before I'm ready and the reason yeah
it's not because you don't eat like I
said that before it's not because you
eat a lot it's not because you don't eat
a lion that the lion is not gonna eat
you so yeah I Gotta Give It props to the
fact that she understood that she chose
the way she worded I like the way she
wore it she said I choose the wrong
people whatever okay so she she knows
she's the wrong people because a lot of
people out there are like why do I
attract
the wrong p and I'm like okay once the
person is attracted what do you do
the person is attracted what do you do
you let the person in they didn't choose
them they fell in love I understand what
you're saying that's what I'm that's
exactly what I'm saying that's not a
choice no that's what I'm saying is that
they stumbled into it a relationship I
understand what eggs
oh imagine being in a nine month stumble
it's like okay
and sometimes
y'all don't listen you do not want to
listen you want to assume stuff when
stuff was clear
no but I thought that she would do this
and you do that no I said I would do
that but I thought how I don't know I
just thought it no no no you said and
forget what he's saying that's where I
want to be and you really wish
oh positive thinking is gonna happen
what ends up happening is I just end up
getting hurt because I love really
really hard
and I just choose the wrong people and
unfortunately I don't know if
I'm ever gonna have it in me to
like find someone that like is healthy
or good for me like I obviously want
that but that's not what I'm attracted
to and so I'm not like I'm not gonna
sell for someone that I'm not attracted
to just because
like they're good for me okay we're good
we're good that's a funny sentence I was
good I was with her I was with her I'm
not gonna settle for someone that's good
for me just because I'm not attracted to
them I don't think it's necessarily that
bad I think in the end whatever she's
attracted to is clearly bad for her yeah
and she's not gonna settle on something
less because she's just she just doesn't
make her feel anything or you just have
to understand why you're attracted to
those bad things
that's another perspective that's not
like some good good theory sessions
right is she taking a break then then
good for her yeah
oh man ain't [__] at least she being
like man I don't know how to choose it
I'm not like I like trash
I don't know what it is I just love I'd
be going through dumpsters every day
every time to people like yo come in
this hotel room it's five star and I
just be just diving in the dumpster
looking for the nicest banana peel to
take home I don't want a real meal
I want maggots and leftovers it's like
if she knows it different she knows it I
know that sounds really bad I I hope
that makes sense I'm just genuinely at a
point right now where I would so much
rather be like single and alone and in
peace
than ever get into something ever again
where I'm the one that's left
so hurt I am done putting my emotions on
the line for someone and I'm done crying
over men because it's just not worth it
for my health at all but yeah I think
what really hurts is just like having a
vision of thinking that something's
gonna work out and then
you start seeing someone's true colors
and then you realize that it's probably
not right for you so yeah I'm done I
give up wait there's a follow-up so
apparently someone says about a man
I'm going out tonight
I'm gonna be completely transparent
right now
I just finished having the biggest
mental breakdown
and I want to talk about it I have a
friend that was in a four-year
relationship and she was broken up with
in March I randomly got this urge to
text her today to just ask her how she's
doing and if she's feeling any better
and our conversation was going on and
she told me that she's already dating
someone new
and I just want to preface this by
saying I am so happy for her that she
was able to find someone that fast
um
I'm so happy for her that she found
someone that well you know who else was
talking in the corner
it goes to the bitter [__] popped out
of nowhere this is this is that [__] I'm
so happy for you and I am so glad that
you've found someone in your life that
really loves you why not you [__]
I'm tremendously elated and I'm gonna
like all your photos on Instagram
[Music]
[__] hoe you guys look like such a great
couple but you ain't
does he love you
[Applause]
oh that's what I feel like we going on
tour are we coming to cities near you we
want to see you [__] face to
face where you at we gonna be doing
shows all summer well this summer we're
doing three shows we're doing Detroit
Pittsburgh and Washington DC but
afterwards we were going to England
we're going to be going all across
America Asia so if you want to get
tickets make sure you guys go to the
website all right put your name so we
can email you as soon as those tickets
come out for your area we won't bombard
you with nothing else okay I promise
yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna be
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys but I cannot
help
but compare myself to that and ask
myself
why is it so easy for some people to
date and find relationships that fast
let alone that quickly after just ending
a really long relationship okay I'm
gonna say this
Loki she got crazy eyes
hiki
maximum key key
oh key set [__] kids of the city
you know them eyes were like where were
you last night but it's just not where
were you she's like peering through your
[__] soul that's what she got right
now Keith of the city she looking
through this screen and I'm feeling the
intensity of like her clinginess
maybe I'm broken or maybe this is my
brain
but I find dating so ridiculous
sometimes I have to be self-deprecating
or I have to just kind of look at myself
and just laugh at the whole situation so
when I see someone be this flat and
monotone and dead serious about dating
over two three videos like really just
sad and depressed about the whole thing
I just gotta look like okay you can't
even find any laughter or slightest bit
of joy in this whole [__] go go watch go
watch uh uh
uh Abba in the bush story that's that's
yeah yeah that's a good one I'm taking
bigger L's than any of this [__] and
then you've got people like me who are
in their late 20s and cannot even get
someone to want to commit to them
that laugh was scary
that was not a laugh laugh that was a
containment of the yeah and I'm not
gonna lie it really makes me feel
terrible about myself like I cannot help
but wonder if there is something wrong
with me genuinely like is do I put forth
some sort of repellent like I truly do
not understand and I'm not saying that
my friend and this guy are gonna
actually go anywhere I'm just saying
like the fact that she was just able to
find someone so quickly that she likes
and he likes her in return and he's
willing to treat her well and take her
on dates
like why can't I have the same
you you can't have the same you just
don't really like most of the guys who
want to treat you all
that's it the same
I just do not understand
the way these things go
and
like I just wonder when will it ever be
my turn
everything about this girl's energy just
like none of it radiates Joy or like
happiness to be around when you are with
the right person you will never feel
like you are asking them of too much so
I'm here to confirm that every single
thing that I said in that video is
completely true and since everyone is
asking yes I did end things with that
guy that I was talking about in the
video and I am so excited to say that I
am currently talking to someone new that
is actually giving me the bare minimum
of daily communication this is a
sickness I'm happy for you my girl the
highest order let's go there is no hope
for this one I just think it's a bit of
a red flag yeah it is when you announce
a breakup or like so you stop seeing
some guy and you and you're this giddy
about someone you just met especially
when you got a really bad dating history
of not getting men to commit to you the
fact that you're only in the early
stages with this person and you're
bragging yo you want to know how
pathetic this is go ahead she bragging
about the fact that this guy meets the
bare minimum and I am so excited to say
that I am currently talking to someone
new that is actually giving me the bare
minimum of daily communication that's
how I put I I'm not even trying to clown
home girl right she could have just been
a happy off life she's bragging online
with a dumb looking smile on her face
because he meets the bare minimum but
anyways I'm just saying it's not like I
don't feel or I don't understand that
for a lot of people being their late 20s
idea I've never ever been to
relationship with some really stressful
I can empathize with all that but some
of you [__] need to find joy in
your life
because you need to find happiness
before you find a penis now I literally
have someone in my life that is giving
me verbal affirmation telling me that
when he's busy he's not going to be able
to answer me as quickly like that is the
way it should so again to all of the
women that watch my videos and say
they've been with someone for x amount
of time who is me
oh
uh honestly I don't want a rag on a home
grow up I hope it works out so I think
it will absolutely not
um uh yeah anyways uh I'm just saying
that's it for me